all right so the the art cannot be
gentle you can be the point of Budo
training is that you become a gentle
person
the art you you can't be throwing people
through space to land and crashed into a
planet and that's going to be a gentle
thing do you understand hey okay don't
want fool yourself
but you can by working on who you are
you can't become a gentle person so I
could have a pillow a pillow right we
used to do this when I was a kid we
getting these pillow fights and everyone
thought can't get hurt with those
pillows but we would tighten the
pillowcase so that all the feathers
would be at the bottom right and we
would to hand it and you hit that in
someone's face and you knock the heck
out of them
it hurt okay you can do that with
anything there's no gentle tools or
violent tools there's gentle people and
violent people you understand so we have
to train in an art that is in itself
very dangerous so we have to figure out
how we as hookahs keep ourselves from
getting hurt that's how that's why you
learn how to fall properly and then is
noggin right we have to make sure we're
not going to hurt our partners so I can
only throw them as hard as they can take
as good as their Kimi is that's how hard
I can throw them got it so if your chemi
is not good then we cannot throw you
hard then you do not really learn the
art do you understand that it's kind of
like I have what's what's your favorite
drink
sir Fanta what Fanta orange does any
would have a favorite drink where's your
favorite drink Fanta orange okay so you
love Fanta orange and I have this big
giant two-liter bottle of Fanta orange
and it's a hot day you got a pizza dog
from dazed augurs salty or you just so
thirsty I need something that delicious
Fanta orange and you have so much but
you bring me a thimble it and you get a
thimble word is that gonna quench your
thirst
no that's kind of what it's like when
you're Cammy is not safe is not skillful
then you have to see less of the art do
you understand so we had a back brave
fall on this technique and some of you
okay some of you not okay
some of you falling with the wrong foot
right
some of you falling with the right foot
we all have to be in the right place
everyone's who Kimmy has to go up
because as our UK has become less
skillful the quality of the dojo drops
got it you would never go to a
restaurant that served you symbols
symbols of orange Fanta right your
wedding cut you would you would go let's
not go there because you only get a
symbol of Lawrence right you would go
let's go over there cuz they got
72-ounce
cost the same as that symbol right so
everyone has that responsibility in the
dojo everyone to get your chemi skills
up high enough so that we can train
safely at higher faster levels you
understand when you're kami is not good
enough
you're not seeing anything of this art
nothing you're gonna go off maybe you
get bored and you go oh I want to do
this I'm gonna play football you don't
nothing of Aikido because you just
brought a symbol okay so we're gonna
spend some time in I key to really
working on this back break fall so we
know which foot to fall down on we can't
be making that mistake I've seen that
mistake in the grown up classes it's
just bad
broken things break shoulders wrists
elbows neck pain for a long time not
good okay so we have to fix that agreed
right okay let's line up hey wait